un último empuje por el apruebo o el
rechazo las campañas cerraron en Chile
de cara al plebiscito sobre el nuevo
texto de la Constitución que reemplazará
la Carta Magna de 1980 establecida
durante la dictadura de Augusto pinochet
en la capital Santiago miles se unieron
al grito de apruebo Los Defensores del
nuevo texto lo apoyan entre otros por su
carácter paritario plurinacional y por
establecer a Chile como en estado social
y democrático de derecho unos términos
que no se mencionaban en la Constitución
anterior la profe y profesores de chile
este 4 de septiembre
votamos a prueba porque por fin por fin
Tendremos una constitución en donde la
educación es concebida como un derecho
humano fundamental una perspectiva
opuesta reunió a los detractores de la
nueva Carta Magna con un cierre más
íntimo en un hotel de Santiago critican
que el proceso de elaboración de la
Constitución excluyó a varios sectores
de la sociedad y que Su contenido es
ideologizado además cuestionan las
modificaciones al sistema político
las razones son múltiples es un texto
que no a mi juicio no le ofrece una
esperanza chile
ofrece
propuestas extrañas en materia de de
plurinacionalidad el sistema político
que nos entregan un ensayo peligroso
el plebiscito de este domingo Sella un
largo camino de la redacción de la nueva
constitución
derivada de las multitudinarias
protestas del país en 2019 buscaba
acabar con el descontento social y a
pesar de que en 2020 más del 78% de la
población voto por redactar una nueva
constitución las encuestas recientes
plantean una alta probabilidad de que el
texto sea rechazado una campaña plagada
de desinformación y noticias falsas que
ha polarizado a la sociedad chilena el
voto es obligatorio y los indecisos
jugarán un rol clave